hello um
and welcome
to getting started with julia and
machine learning
my name is
anthony bloom
i am a senior research fellow at the
university of auckland and i'm joined
today
by samuel
ocon
who works for the applied machine
learning research group
at the technical university of kaiser
lautern
and also the german research center for
the artificial intelligence
so before we
go much further let me explain how we
are going to communicate
um
so we will be taking our questions from
uh using a forum called pigeonhole
and uh you can see there on the screen
uh a link also there's a banner i hope
that has appeared
to show you where to go and let me just
have it show you a little bit so what
that looks like
so i'm going to move
my particular
pigeonhole
um
picture here so you'll have something
like this questions you're going to
enter questions in the space here and
they'll appear here on the screen and
you can up up and down vote them
and um samuel and i will be both
answering questions verbally depending
on who's speaking and then the other
will also be making written answers to
questions
and and these will appear um in the
comments so you may have to click on the
comments to see answers i guess i'm i'm
new to this forum myself so
i have a little patience
all right so that's what that's about
that's how we'll be interacting now um
you can feel free to use the
uh stream yard chat i guess if you would
like to
communicate among uh with other
participants
um but we won't be monitoring that forum
we'll just be monitoring the questions
that you post at pigeonhole
so uh
i'm now going to outline a little bit
how the workshop's going to work so
we'll start off by i'm going to point
and sort of introduce you to the
workshop resources
and and get you uh going with a little
installation that's going to run help
the second part of the workshop uh run a
little smoother
after that i'll give a kind of a mini
well while that's going i'll give a kind
of a mini uh lecture on supervised
learning
just
the kind of learning that we're going to
focus here
in this workshop and then there'll be a
longer um
section after that
introducing just julia basic so it'll be
a live coding session where you can keep
up with what we're doing
and we'll go through julia basic so be
kind of the core part of the workshop
after that i'm i'm going to um
towards the end of that i'm going to
introduce you
to a second way of interacting with
julia we're going to start interacting
just at the command line and towards the
end of that we'll we'll be interacting
via what's called a pluto notebook
and um
and there'll be a shorter section on
things called data frames from this
using these notebooks uh data frames are
uh
containers for
manipulating
tabular data in memory uh a sort of a
basic staple for data science and then
after that i'll be handing over to
samuel who will
help you build a machine learning model
using
a toolbox called mlj
which we are developers of so
that's how the workshop is going to run
now um i don't see any questions yet i'm
hoping that
uh people hear me ah there's a question
that must mean i'm getting through to
somebody on the planet okay so where can
i find the workshop resources
and the linkedin page
okay so i think that's question that is
already answered
maybe that's a comment okay so i'll
carry on for now
and uh
take yourself so now just go ahead and
have it find yourself
at the juliacom website
i'm going to take you to the resources
for the workshop now so once you're
there
go ahead and click on the schedule
and hopefully you'll get today's
schedule which for me is wednesday but
for you probably will say thursday
because you're mostly most of you are
probably in a
different part of the planet
and click on our workshop which is the
second one there
now if you go all the way to the bottom
of that page you'll see a title
resources and something that says hello
julia
you just go ahead and click uh
there
and that will take you to the to a
github repository which collects
together the resources
extended resources for this workshop so
this includes things that we're going to
go through during the workshop but also
other
helpful material
i'll just point out a few key things for
now
there'll be slides
from the talk actually eventually
there'll be extended
version of the slide to give you the
talk
and there are a few
useful cheat sheets here one for julia
itself
one for data frames and one for the
machine learning toolbox mlj that we're
going to talk about
you will also be able to um
by clicking on this link here see all a
number of demonstrations that we won't
get time to present in in the workshop
but you may find useful
um
and uh notebooks in various forms
also reproducing what we will be doing
in the workshop
but more about that later
okay so if i just
go back to here
the next step that we need to do
together here is to
install some
extra resources that will help some of
the workshop later on
go a little quicker
so click on here at the very top of the
hello julia repo
and that will take you to this page
uh here so if i just to show you again
if you go to the top of the
resources page and you click here
then you'll come to this important page
here
now
we're assuming that everyone here has
already installed julia on their
computer
version 1.7
and now i'm going to give you some
instructions
which is going to which is basically
what these what this this is going to do
for you is
install a customized version of the
notebooks that that we're going to use
these pluto notebooks you don't need to
understand these instructions um you
just need to follow them and hopefully
it'll all go smoothly so go ahead and
copy this first block of code here by
clicking in the on the copy paste icon
in the corner
and
now what you need to do is boot up a
julia session and i'm assuming that you
already
know how to do that
for me that means
i launched my julio sessions from uh
from the ripple from from sorry from a a
shell a unix shell a terminal you might
know this as a console if you're working
from windows and i just type julia
and that will boot up at julia session
some of you may need to click on an icon
on your desktop somewhere
to get to open up this sort of a
view that you see now
so the at the end of the day what you
what you're aiming to get is a little
prompt here that says julia
and once you get to that prompt
um you're going to paste that code that
we just copied
before
that should start some kind of a process
happening
it's um
as long it won't look exactly what you
see here but it looks something like
what you see here and as long as you're
not seeing red everything's going fine
now if this doesn't work for you that's
not the end of the day you'll still be
able to
follow along with most of the workshop
and um
and participate um so
but i expect it to work for most people
now go ahead and make sure you hit
return a couple of extra times to make
sure you execute that very last line
which is set up
okay so um
while that's going
i'm now going to
in working in the background this is
going to take about a few minutes like
seven minutes or so
i'm going to start the kind of mini
lecture on on machine learning
i'm just going to check my other
questions i don't see any uh pressing
questions here
um
i think i've answered the question where
to find workshop resources
and now i'm going to uh
add that link just to be um
on the banner there
as well let me go ahead and do that
so that people can find the uh resources
if they
come late all right so now we're going
to talk for just a 10 minutes or so
about machine learning
i'm going to start with a
clarification
and so you often you'll hear people talk
about machine learning and particularly
in i've i see in the julia community and
they they'll often mean when they use
that word they'll mean something that
i would call deep learning or
neural networks
and for me these are different things so
for me uh deep learning and neural
networks are as a special
class of algorithms in machine learning
and when i use the word machine learning
i'm actually talking about something
more general so a more general class of
algorithms for doing
machine learning
here's a picture you don't need to
fully grasp but just to give you an idea
of the variety of um
of machine learning models so every kind
of little white box here is some kind of
machine learning model
some kind of algorithm for learning
and um
you know
it's quite a diversity and also many
different ways to kind of try and
organize machining learning algorithms
it's not actually a simple exercise and
we see here that the
sort of neural network type models
account for just a small part of that
now neural networks uh deep learning
methods uh very six have been very
successful in the area of
image processing
and video and that kind of thing
but chances are if you're moving to
other applications you'll want to know
about some other kinds of models not
just
neural networks
because
chances are other models may perform
better and very often they're they're
actually easier to train than your
networks
so with that clarification out of the
way let's talk about
supervised learning
so supervised learning
is about trying to predict some
particular variable which we call the
target variable given that we know
some other variables in the problem
which we'll collectively refer to as x
now we're not learning to do this in a
vacuum the idea is that we actually know
both the
the variables both the target variable
and the
other variables
uh historically we have some data about
those things
and we want to take that data and then
use it to make predictions
of the target when we don't know what it
is anymore but just the other variables
so
let's leave the abstract and give you
some examples so
you may be a meteorologist for example
and you've measured the temperature and
pressure various places on the planet so
that gives us a bunch of uh these
so-called input features x longitude
latitude temperature and pressure
and then you've also support i suppose
measured the wind speed
but then the idea is you want to go to
some other different some new place on
on the earth
uh where you've measured the temperature
and pressure or average
temperature and pressure or whatever and
you would like to give a kind of
prediction of what the wind speed is
so there you have some features and and
the target is the wind speed in that
case
another example might be uh
you are um
doing uh genetics or you're a biologist
or a uh
someone like that and your your
the input features here are dna
sequences so you're looking at genes
you're looking at
genetic sequences and the thing you're
trying to predict is whether
a person is likely to get a certain
disease based on their
their genes
you might be classifying emails junk or
not junk so that's another example
i might be trying to classify
handwritten digits as
0 one two three four five six seven
eight or nine
and um
and then
one one last example that we are going
to get involved in ourselves towards the
end of this
workshop is the titanic disaster
um and in that case
the uh what where the inputs there are
uh properties of the passenger so
for example their sex what class they
traveled what fair they paid where they
got on
and a couple of other features and the
question we're trying to answer is
whether they survived the
disaster or not
so there are a few examples of machine
learning
of supervised learning
applications
now for the purpose of
discussing the machine learning
basic principles
i'm going to turn to yet
another example
where i imagined that we have had you
have thermometers
spread around the house so in each room
of your house has a thermometer
and you are measuring the temperature
say
on the hour in each of those rooms and
you've recorded that information so
you've got some historical
times and rooms and you've also got this
this temperature which is going to be
our y our target variable
so the idea now is at some different
time in in some room you want to know
what you want a prediction of the
temperature maybe it's not on the hour
maybe it's on the half hour or something
now we're going to make this even
simpler and just forget about the room
for a moment just pretend we will just
say in one room
then we can visualize the data our
inputs here are being written on on the
bottom
and the vertical axis here is the
temperature
and we just have a bunch of dots a bunch
of points in in the plane
so i think that remember that what the
problem is what the objective is here is
is to make predictions for new inputs
and the way we do that is we fix one way
we could do that is to fit some kind of
curve to the data
so we might try to fit a straight line
or maybe a cubic or maybe something a
polynomial of some higher order
and
we're not so concerned here about the
algorithm which
picks out a particular curve
for the purpose of this workshop we just
regard that as a black box
but we are concerned about
how one goes about deciding
which of these models is actually going
to be the one we should use in practice
so uh we can already kind of we already
have a little bit of suspicion about
this
this purple curve or pink curve here
because although it goes through every
single data point here nicely
um it's got a lot of wobbles in it and
that seems to be some a bit a bit
strange
so how we go about assessing
uh the various models
well what we really to do that
objectively what we really need is more
data
so
now i'm going to correct myself and say
well actually i wasn't measuring the
temperature every hour i was actually
measuring it more often i have half
validator as well
and that's what we're going to look at
in deciding which model we ought to use
so here's now all the data that i that i
had not just the data i used to train
the model but some extra data which are
held back
let's throw away the training data
and just look at the held back data or
test data as we call it
so now we're in a position to more
objectively
decide which of these various models are
the ones that are going to
are likely to perform the best
on on new data
to make this a proper quantitative thing
we have to make a decision about exactly
how we define the the error
um and we can in this example
for we could do something like measure
the sum of the square deviations from
the curve and our points so that would
be one way to to quantify the the
measure
once we have that agreed upon
measure or metric as we call it we can
then pick the curve which minimizes uh
the error and away we go
so that essentially is is the machine
learning uh supervised machine learning
workflow in a nutshell the base most
basic
form of it and
sort of from a philosophical point of
view all supervised learning really is
just curve fitting
i mean you can kind of think of it that
way
if you like
now
um
i'll just summarize a little bit so
what's the setup here the setup is
always the same you have some historical
data which you've divided into
things you call features and things you
call the target variable
and the basic workflow is you split the
historical data into separate training
and test sets the test set you kind of
put in a cupboard lock throw away the
key
and
don't touch when you're training
then in the second step you train the
model using the training set
you get model predictions
now open up the cupboard and grab your
test set and
get predictions for the test features
call that y hat for example then you
compare that y hat with the actual
historical
test values of the target variable
quantify that using some agreed upon
measure metric
and you repeat the process for different
models or different values of
a particular model's hyperparameter so
a parameter is something like
the degree of the polynomial that we
looked at in that example before
so that's the basic machine learning
workflow i'm going to have a look here
and see if there any
questions coming up about that
okay i think i'm going to mark this as
answered oh it's answered already all
good okay so we seem to be
on on track here
so now that's um
a little mini lecture
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to oh i'm going to say one more
thing
about this
so if we go back to our examples we see
um
the targets actually come in two
different kind of flavors
there's the continuous sort of variable
which we had in the temperature example
another example would be this real
estate one which i didn't mention where
we're trying to predict the selling
price of a house
and so
there you can kind of literally think of
supervised learning as as fitting a
curve or a hyper surface in higher
dimensions
but then we have this other kind of
variable like uh
is junk or is not junk or survived or is
not did not survive
these are discrete these are examples of
district discrete target variables and
there we can't really think of this as a
curve anymore um not literally
i'm and and this example that we're
going to talk about later this titanic
example is is it is of that kind so in
this case we are trying to the thing
we're trying to predict is discrete
so we call that kind of a problem a
classification problem
and
let me just give you an example of uh of
a classification model that's quite easy
to understand
which is called a decision tree
and this is actually what you're going
to be training at the towards the end of
the workshop
i see a question here i'm just going to
pause for a minute
why are they called hyper parameters and
not parameters
is this an important distinction that's
quite a good question
so let me answer that uh now
so
the
the hyper parameters in your problem
they're things that the user you as the
user kind of fixes
ahead of time
and
uh what we normally call the parameters
of the problem are things that get
learned that
that you as the user don't actually
control directly so you're going to run
for example in in the example of the
fitting
the temperature problem when you're
trying to learn the temperature the
hyper parameter is say the degree of the
polynomial so say i'm going to fix the
i'm going to look for a third degree
polynomial
then you run your algorithm and it fits
a nice third degree
polynomial to your data and what it's
learning there is some coefficients
right the coefficients of your constant
your coefficients of x your coefficients
of x squared and your coefficient of x
cubed so those things are what we tend
to call the parameters of the problem
and the hot the things that get learned
and the hyper parameters these are the
things that you fix ahead of time
now it can happen that this distinction
between parameters and hyperparameters
gets blurred
when you start to automate the
the the
question of the the step in your process
of deciding what hyper parameters to do
to use but in the first step they're
fixed
and then later on as you you try to
optimize and find the best parameter you
may actually automate that process and
in that sense these hyper parameters
become learned parameters so this isn't
a
black and white distinction necessarily
uh let's see we'll
say that that one is
answered
okay so my
right thing
that looks like it's not appearing
anymore okay
all right so now let me talk about this
decision tree
uh so this remember the thick thing
about the titanic disaster so you
got a bunch of passengers and things you
know about them and you want to know
whether they survived the accident or
not
so i'm not going to say how how decision
3 how you find this decision tree but
i'm going to take give you an example of
a decision tree that's that has been fit
to the data uh which is represented by
this picture
and all the decision tree really is a
bunch of questions that you're going to
ask
uh it's when we call it a tree but
really it's an inverted tree and we
start at the top
and the first question in this case is
what gender is the person um okay let's
suppose it was male
and less so then the next question is
what age is is the per is the individual
if we suppose that the age was less than
nine and a half then the tree is telling
us okay we have a conclusion now
you that individual is died in the
accident with a probability uh well a
survival probability of 17
which means that they likely died
so that that's what an example of a
decision tree a very simple kind of idea
um
it's not the most uh
best performing model most of the time
but it's actually the basis of a lot
more of other more sophisticated models
so it's a very nice one to to learn
about
okay so that's all i'm going to do with
the sort of chat chit chat on on the
theory here
it's time now to do some actual um
machine learning
and as i said before i'm in long machine
learning some coding
because machine learning later so now
we're going to go step back now and and
just think about coding and think about
um
basic julia
we have a look at the questions here
okay so what i want you to do now is to
is to open up so there will have been
this process that you uh got started
before somewhere um it looks like
for me it has already ended
um because my i've got back to my julia
prompt here you'll see a bunch of ld
warnings you can just ignore those and
if your process is still going because
your computer runs a little slower or
you had more somehow to install that
doesn't matter because we're not going
to use this yet
so in in any case what you might like to
do now is open a second julia process
so for me that so that might mean
opening a new shell or
console and typing julia again or it may
mean clicking on on an icon icon again
so that you have a second julia process
and that's the one we're going to work
work with here
so once you've got this julia prompt you
can i invite you now to kind of follow
along as best you can with with what i
present now
so the first thing to understand about
julia
is it works just like um you know of
course like a calculator so i can enter
in some
uh
sum like five plus six and it gives me i
hit return and it gives me the answer
the next thing that you want to know
about the rebel it's the most uh useful
thing to know about the raffle is rebel
is that you can use the up and down keys
on your keyboard
to navigate the history so i can go up i
use the up arrow and i'll reproduce the
5.6 if i press the 9 the down arrow then
i'll go back to a blank line so
up arrow i go back to 5 plus 6. now i
can now edit this line and i can use
like something like let's take the
square root of 5
5 6 or maybe let's do 5 plus 4 so i know
what the the answer is actually going to
be
should be three right
and it is so three
so we can do um all the kind of standard
scientific functions
uh
are provided built in so i can do things
like compute the sign of a number
uh in julia pi is p i so
that's the sign of a number
and the next now another very important
thing is how we get help about a
particular function like this and the
way we do that is using the question
mark so you're at the julia prompt and
you type in a question mark
and that changes the prompt to yellow
and it now says help
if i hit delete then that will disappear
but let's hit the question mark again
and now i can type in say for example
sign and i'll get a description of the
sign function and how it works and what
it is
okay
um
the next the thing we're going to talk
about this is the something that's
pretty important if you're doing any
kind of maths or stats and that is uh
arrays in particular we'll talk about
vectors and and matrices
i'm just give me a stick here
lost one of my screens
right
so uh
how do you define a simple vector in
julia well it's you use square brackets
um
and you do something like this so here's
a vector one two three
have a length that's something that's
useful
to know
um and
the way we access a vector is we use
square brackets as well i mean like say
for example if i want the the second
value of that vector i go v square
brackets too it's pretty straightforward
um
if i want to the vectors are also
mutable which means i can change
individual elements so if i wanted to
let's use the up arrow here to save some
typing
i can actually
change the second element so maybe i
want to make that 42 and now if i type v
then you can see i've changed the
the second element of the vector so
vectors are mutable we say
you can also change their lengths um
we'll see an example of that in a minute
um what about matrices or well what
about
should i think of how should i think of
this i should think of this really as a
column vector the way it's displayed
here even though i enter it as a kind of
a
a row
you should think of this as a column
vector how then do i would i
how would i actually define a row well
in that case you leave out the commas so
maybe four five six
with spaces in between that gives you
actually a one by three matrix
which then sort of is suggestive of how
we would define a matrix now it's just a
number of rows so one two three
and you separate the rows either by
entering a return key
like this
or by using a semicolon that will also
work
7 8 9. so
that's how we get a matrix
we can access the elements of a matrix
much like we would a vector but now we
need to say two arguments first for the
uh row and the second for the column
that's not going to work because i have
a fourth column but that will work so
there's the element in the second
row third column
and you can mutate elements just like
you mutate them for vectors
you have for uh you also have a length
for a matrix
which is the
length if you would just join all the
columns together
which is how the matrix is actually
stored internally so that's kind of a
linear index um indexing kind of idea
but then if you want to know the actual
dimensions of the matrix we use a
command called size
now size is returning something a little
bit different this 3 comma 3 here has
round brackets instead of square
brackets and that's what we call a tuple
that's a little different we'll talk
about tuples in a minute
uh
now
julia has sort of basic linear algebra
provided
built in
maybe it doesn't
maybe for this i need what do i have
ah i happen to pick a singular matrix
okay so let me let me let me change that
let's change my matrix to be and we'll
see this later a random matrix and maybe
you'll have better luck
and let's try inverting that matrix
okay that one was not singular
so there's some basically near algebra
provided built in but if you want to do
something more fancy like singular value
decomposition or something then you
would you would import
one of the standard libraries that julia
provides so that's part of the julia
installation
you don't have to download it from
somewhere but you need to actually call
it and the way we would do that is we
would go using
in this case linear algebra
and that would then
allow us to use to do some more advanced
functions
so there you go singular value position
in this matrix okay
we're not going to need to that anywhere
here you can relax
okay so the next very important thing to
do but let me just have a look
for some reason i'm not don't seem to be
seeing many questions
on that page on my admin page so i'm
going to have to keep monitoring here
is there logic in splitting a given data
synthesis okay let me have a look at
some of these questions this is
seems like they're being answered
here's one that's not answered is there
an argument to the square root function
to return 3 and not 3.0
aha well that's a subtle question um
well um
the the real important question comes
after it's if what if i want to test
whether 3 is equal to 3.0
so
the the question was you know uh
maybe i'm not going to answer the
question completely but if i take the
square root of 9 to have a look at that
we saw that was 3.0
you might be thinking about why doesn't
it return an integer integer if it can
um well this particular function will
return uh won't return an injury returns
a float as you see here but but what you
can safely do here is test do this kind
of testing so compare three the integer
to three the float and you'll see that
it's still true
so while
you might be surprised that the square 9
is not an integer it's still something
that is equal to the corresponding
integer
so i'm not completely answering the
question there but perhaps clarifying
why why it doesn't really matter
in some sense
um
so we'll call that an answered
okay
i'll now continue
and now the next thing i i want to
talk about is variables so
variables in julia may not work the way
you're used to if you're coming from say
r
or
maybe
a high a low level language like c
they are what you would be used to if
you're coming from
python so
the variables in julia really just kind
of pointers to objects which exist in
their own right and they're very
ephemeral
in some sense so let me explain that
really with an example let's suppose we
have a vector
um one two three or one three five i
don't know here's a vector
what that uh bit of code actually says
is it says
first of all it says create a somewhere
in memory a vector an object which we
call a vector which has these elements
which exists
in its own right so this object exists
same on the computer on its own right so
that's step one create this thing
and step two is saying well the symbol u
is is understood now to point to this
particular object
okay it's pointing to this object it's
not literally this object it's a symbol
which is redirecting redirecting us to
this object whenever we call it
now if i go ahead and and say
say you
let's say w equals to u
then that command
that expression there is telling us now
okay
i now want the symbol w
to point to whatever u points to so sure
enough if i type w at
the prompt there i'm getting
one three five but i'm not just getting
one three five i'm i'm actually
literally recall uh um accessing the
precise new part of memory so this this
w equals u here it didn't copy the one
three five there's no new uh ob you know
part of memory that now contains a copy
of one three five it is literally the
same thing so if i now go ahead and and
say change uh say the uh
let's make it the middle element and i
say let that be equal to 42
so now i've actually changed that look
one of the
locations in memory now with this
command
but it's
but now um
because w points to the same thing sorry
then if i have asked the question what
is w i see that that has also changed
but that might be a little bit of a
surprise to you if you're coming from
say ah or some other language so just be
aware of that
variables work a little bit differently
uh kind of a kind of corollary of this
is that functions in in julia all kind
of work by pass by reference if if that
makes some sort of sense to you
it doesn't if it doesn't it doesn't
matter
all right let's check my questions
okay
so it looks like sam is doing a good
quick job here of answering my questions
for me
all right
so let me carry on
um
and the next thing i'm going to talk
about is tuples which we saw before
when we looked at the size of an array
so in a tuple let's define one ourselves
a couple uh
looks lumped in something like this and
it's it's very commonly used when we're
dealing with uh objects which have
different types so maybe i'm mixing uh
an integer here with say a float and
maybe uh
what we'll
we'll talk about strings in a minute
three different um
kinds of objects
uh
and i use round brackets and
this is sort of sort of like a vector
because i mean it's just just a string
of different uh objects but it's
different in a couple of respects the
first way it's different is that i can't
mutate
the the elements of a of a couple i can
access them the same way so i could do
that t one of three but if i change try
and change cat to dog i'm going to get a
complaint
so these are immutable we can't they
can't be changed the elements you also
can't make them longer or shorter
so that has certain advantages
which i'm not really going to go into
but basically performance might be an
issue whether you decide to use a a
tuple or a
um
a vector
just as a rule of thumb if
you're you know if you're needing to
mutate of course you're going to use a
vector but also typically when the data
is always the same type then using
vectors are not necessary but
often when you have a mixed type you may
want to think about using a tuple
then tuples come in a named version so
let's use the up arrow key and get back
to this earlier definition oh it doesn't
want to do it the way yeah okay
i've got
i'm okay now it's working so go back and
edit this thing here
couples come in a name version which
means we can give the the various
components of our couple names suppose
we can call this x y and z
and this mean and we can then this gives
us then the option of accessing elements
by name that's kind of the main point so
i go t1 dot x and that gives me the the
x the thing we named as x
uh then we have uh let's introduce a few
more basic types in julia
we have strings
and there's sort of three
basic string like things that we will
encounter in this workshop the first was
an ordinary string which we sort of
already saw before uh
in close and double quotes
the string behaves a little bit like a
vector so i can
access say
the third character of my string
and what is returned here is the second
kind of object that
is string like which is we call a
character
so now i i'll i'll define a character
myself
a character equals and i use now single
quotes so maybe c
okay
and i maybe so then so that's a single
character is considered a different kind
of object
uh and the elements of a string us are
these characters
then there's a third kind of uh string
like thing
which is called a symbol in julia and
that'll be something you haven't seen in
say a language like python or matlab
i'm not going to say too much about them
but i'm going to tell you how to define
one so here is a symbol
and it's
sort of quite s
here's the symbol cat
and
this is what is called in the business
and intern string i didn't actually know
what i mean what that really meant i had
to look that up myself
not long ago and i'm not going to try
and explain it it's something to do with
the way that the thing is stored in
memory
um
and we won't i won't say much about it
in this workshop but uh basically the
the
the reason they exist is to do with uh
julia's possibility for language
reflection so in julia uh julia can take
bits of julia code
bits of the language and actually
manipulate it so that's that's that's a
very powerful idea it's called
metaprogramming
and associated with that are things
called macros we're not going to talk
about them here but these symbols are
kind of like the most atomic um
objects in that in in that whole
business of expressions you know code
expressions that you manipulate the
basic atoms in that are called symbols
and
you'll see them come up but you just
think of them as a different kind of
string
another kind of basic
object that you might want to learn
about is a dictionary but i'm just going
to pass over that for now
and talk about functions which are
going to be more important
let's see the questions how are we doing
here
uh a question is uh here's an
interesting question are tuples the same
as dictionaries in python so tuples and
dictionaries we haven't told you what a
dictionary is but we have dictionaries
they are very similar um except in uh in
julia dictionaries mutable so tup
whereas tuples are not
and dictionaries have no associated
order with the keys whereas a tuple has
a has a has a fixed order so there's two
differences between couples and
dictionaries but since i'm not talking
about dictionaries i won't
elaborate a lot further
so there's a question about whether um
tuples of l-type any well a tuple
will perform let's say an effective type
l type any i think that's gonna i won't
answer that here because
um
[Music]
technical question
okay i think we'll carry on okay
um so we're gonna talk about functions
now how are we doing with
time okay
we need to uh
keep an eye okay so there's a couple of
ways of defining functions in julian
functions are important because it saves
us having to
write out the same thing over and over
again so
the simplest way to find a function is
just
how you would do it if you were in a
math class
and this carat symbol here means to the
power of so this is the squaring
function
so you just uh for example we can square
the number 3 and get 9.
so that's the first way you can define a
function another thing you can do which
turns out to be very useful is to define
a function
without giving it a name so this
function got we had to give it a name we
called it foo
but you can define functions without
giving them names so the way you do that
is you go
x maps to with this
minus greater than so we call these two
things as kind of one symbol here
x
squared
now that doesn't have a name so julia
gives it a name and calls it
a general generic function number one
we know we can't as users we don't
really have a way of accessing that but
we can apply it to things so for example
i could take the number well let me show
you something first here's some here's
some syntax which is
sometimes useful suppose i take that foo
function
and i want to apply it apply it
after the fact so to speak so i've got
an input 3 and now i want to apply foo
after the fact then i use this symbol
here vertical bar and a greater than
symbol it's called the pipe symbol and
then that will give me nine
um
but i can but i can also do the same
thing but with with the anonymous
function
i never gave a name to
right
that does the thing and i can chain
these things things together so here is
square twice essentially
there's a bill
that's a bit about anonymous functions
anonymous functions are
useful often when you are
calling when the argument of a function
is another function and you don't want
to give it a name you just want to
stick it in there
the third way that you can define a
function is what you would use when the
function is more complicated and maybe
involve some logic
um and then you right actually write out
the word function and then
foo of x or whatever it is
maybe i'll call it
two let's make it different
and then you just maybe you've got
something a bit more complicated um
y equals x just define a new variable
and then maybe w is equal to y and then
okay at the end of the day you return
something which is the output of the
function let's return w and and and this
should now be the cubing function
function
so if i just test that works yes it
works so that's the third way of
defining function
okay so the next thing we need to talk
about um
is
we're not we're not really going to
introduce you to much in the way of
actual programming we won't needed too
much of it um but we will do something
that sort of very basic program which is
iteration so i want to talk about a
couple of different ways that you can
iterate um
operations in julia
so the thing we're going to iterate here
is is the squaring operation and what we
won't want to do is square the numbers
from 1 to 10.
so here's the first way you can do it um
if you're coming from python this is
probably pretty close to the code you
would write so first you define we
define ourselves an empty vector we call
it squares okay so that's how you define
an empty vector
and then we're going to do a what's
called a for loop so we're going to say
4
x in a bunch of values
and what we're going to write in this
case is 1 colon 10
which you can think of as
essentially something that
is
representing the integers from one to
ten
then you go on a new line and now i'll
indent the next bit of code
but the the actual spaces i'm entering
here have no
uh syntactic significance
it's not like this this is not python
where spaces make a difference
um and then what i'm going to do now is
i'm going to push to the end of this
vector called squares which starts off
as empty
the value of x to the power of 2
whatever that is
so that's
taking the squares vector and adding to
the end of it and you'll see here this
exclamation mark here
that you should regard as part of the
variable name push push exclamation mark
the xml is part of the name of the
function
and it's a convention in julia to use a
question mark at the end of the name
when that function is mutating one or
more of its arguments and because we're
adding to the end of this squares vector
we are mutating it we're changing
we're not copying squares first or
something
where we're just adding to the end of it
and now oops um
now i'm going to
make a new line
and say end which closes the four block
and now if i if i type out squares
i should see
this the integers squared from under 10.
okay
the second way we can um square numbers
to ten so now is here's an another way
of doing the same thing is to use what's
called comprehension syntax which is we
kind of immediately write down our
vector so we start with a square bracket
and
we use comprehension syntax which is uh
the same idea as the way you often write
the definitions of sets in mathematics
if that's something you're familiar with
so here's the syntax you say
give me the vector of all x to the power
of 2
or x being in
numbers from 1 to 10.
that's a shorthand version of what we
just did before that's called
comprehension
a third method of doing the same thing
is to apply what we call the map
function
which is a function which takes as one
of its arguments another function
so
we don't have a name for this function
so we're going to use an anonymous
function
if we
well we did define squared before but
let's use the anonymous function for
practice so that's the first argument of
the map function and the second argument
is the thing you want to apply that
function to in this case the numbers
from one to ten
and then we get
the same thing we got before
and finally we have even uh more terse
form of of the same thing essentially
which is
borrow some syntax from matlab
so now if i take the numbers from one to
ten and i need in this case to put them
in brackets um to resolve some ambiguity
and if i would just raise this to the
power of two then that wouldn't make
sense because you can't just take
vectors and and square them
however if i put this little dot here
before the squared symbol
then that's telling us what we want to
do is perform this operation
element-wise that is we want to square
each of these elements of this vector
that is we want to broadcast the way the
the language goes like this we want to
broadcast the squaring operation over
the elements of this vector so then that
is the shortest way of doing that
iteration
okay
so now
that's iteration
we've now going to talk a little bit
about random numbers
um
how do we generate random numbers in
julia we can do this the simplest random
number call is just a call with no
arguments which gives you a single
number randomly
chosen between 0 and 1 using the uniform
distribution
we can already see how we can randomly
generate
a whole matrix of such things
and if instead of uh if i if i go back
here with the up arrow here and edit and
i put an n there then that will just
change the
sampling to the
standard normal
we will do that in a slightly different
way in a minute
um if we want to get multiple uh
suppose we want to have
three random uh numbers instead of just
one and of course we could have just
done that but that's just a special case
of already essentially the thing we did
above
we can randomly sample from some set so
maybe we have a set of integers
a
b
and c
so they're sorry i randomly uh from a
set a vector of characters i can
randomly set sample from that maybe i
get i want 10 of those
that's how you do that and then and um
there is also if you want to do more
fancy kind of
random things there's a standard library
called random which but i'm not going to
demonstrate that now
one thing you need to know is that some
statistic functions are not built in
so you have to import the statistics
library for example to use the mean
function so here's a random
number from
1 to 10.
let's get say 100 of them
hopefully that is something close to
five and it is so
for that mean function to work we need
to import statistics
which will provide some other things and
uh
okay so
that is
uh how far we're going to go for now
using the repel
we're now going to switch gears now and
attempt if we can to get to try and
interact with julie in a slightly
different way which is using a notebook
i'm just checking over my questions here
is the push the same as append
so you use push to uh the question is
there's a command called a push and
there's a command called append
um
pushing is for
adding a single element and appending is
to is for adding um a
a another a vector basically is the
answer that question
okay
i'm now so now let's move up let's now
go find that
process that we that first julia process
that we worked on before hopefully it's
finished and it's worked
if it didn't work for you don't panic
you might try following along by
continuing to work in the repel
that's what we call this environment
that we've been working in so far the
rebel
called repl
um
but uh
actually i notice you probably can't see
the bottom of this because of the banner
so let me just remove the banner for the
moment
how do i do that i gotta hide the banner
okay so then uh
let's let's let me show you how to get
this with this these notebooks going so
now what we're going to do is go back to
our
browser to this page here
that we we got to from the resources for
the workshop now and what we want to do
now is select this second block of code
here by clicking on the copy paste icon
here and what this is going to do is
it's going to launch a notebook now in
the normal workflow uh you would launch
a pluto notebook uh in a slightly
different way
um but we're doing a sort of um a
variation on the standard way which is
going to give you customized material
for this workshop so go ahead and copy
that there
and then move go back to one of your
julia
processes now i think we actually have
to quit this process and relaunch the
process so i'm going to do that just to
make sure that this works as intended
so you may have to do that also and then
go ahead and paste that
second code block in
and type return a few times to make sure
you get the the last line of code
if that works for you it should work
relatively quickly and what it should do
is launch
a pluto notebook in a browser
so hopefully that is work going to work
for most of you and what you should see
is what you're seeing on the screen now
all right
and after a moment or so you should even
see a table of contents
so these are notebooks that we actually
specific to this particular workshop
and i'm going to show you one of them
now which is tutorial one so go ahead
when this appears and click on tutorial
one
and what you'll find there
is
actually uh what we've been doing so far
at the ripple stuff about julia being a
calculator stuff about arrays and so on
and you can see here that notebooks have
a a different kind of object they have
several advantages first of all they're
a permanent record of what you're typing
what you're generating
second of all um
you can annotate uh what you
the code with a bunch of you know
titles and and and comments and so on so
that you can it becomes a story that you
tell
the third um
thing about the pluto note which is
specific to pluto notebooks is that they
are reactive and i'm going to explain
that um
very soon so
um that's if we can go back to the table
of contents if you want and you can see
all the material that we're talking
about here is has a notebook form but so
that you can keep up with us we're not
going to just go through the the
notebooks we're going to continue to to
work one line at a time and we're going
to work in a
a blank notebook so how do you get a new
blank notebook well you go up to the
corner here where it says pluto and you
click on pluto
and uh that will bring you to this page
and then you click on open a new
notebook so the second option here
and that should bring up something like
this
and go ahead and click
in this first kind of yellowish looking
box which is called a cell we're now
ready to use the notebook
now i can type things for example maybe
i type x equals four and now if i hit
return that's not going to do anything
because it's just going to start a new
line without doing anything because this
is a notebook it's not the rebel so
let's get rid of that return how do i
execute that code
well you have a couple of options the
first thing is you can you can just
click on this play button
but that gets pretty old pretty quickly
um what i is there's a shortcut for that
and the shortcut is
shift return
so you're hitting the shift key and the
return key
at the same time
people don't understand my aussie accent
shift return you're going to do that at
the same time
and that is going to evaluate the cell
as i said you can also just press this
play button
um now if you want to also uh get a new
cell to write in you instead of doing
shift return you you can do control
return and then that will evaluate the
cell and create a new one
or you can create a new one just by
clicking on these plus symbols
all right
now let's do something with that number
let's
compute the square of x
and
shift return to evaluate it
16 fine
now here's something a bit different
from say jupyter notebooks if you're
familiar with those i go back to the
first cell click up there
so now i'm going to click and i change
the value of x
to say 5 and then
shift return to evaluate
and i find that the second cell is
automatically re-evaluated to 25.
so
the order in which you write things here
um
is is the order in which things gets
executed is literally the way that
things are written so the order in which
you write things of course matters so
this is a bit different um from jupiter
notebooks and this is called reactivity
it has advantages and it has a
disadvantages
and i'm still living learning to live
with some of the disadvantages but it's
a very popular um and it is sometimes
useful
all right so that's the basics of
interaction
um one more thing worth mentioning uh in
general let's go shift return to get a
new box
is that you can
annotate with text so the way you do
that is suppose i want to put in some
comment here is uh um
maybe give
this a name the way i do that is i
actually enter it as code
and i put it as a so into a string so
this is one way i can do this i can
enter a string let's say
chapter one
ah
one
and then shift return and then i see
chapter one displayed there
but it's not displayed in a terribly
exciting way because i've still got
those quotes so the way i get around
that is i edit this and i put md
before that and that md stands for
markdown
which is a special kind of string
maybe you're familiar with markdown
already in which case you'll immediately
want to do something more elaborate for
example in markdown if you put a hash
symbol and a space then that tells
us that we want a first order heading
so there you go if you like markdown
you'll you'll love
pluto notebooks
all right
that's a little bit about how these
pluto notebooks work now i'm going to
return
to our discussion of
basic julia and we're going to move into
a bit of statistics and plotting here
i'm going to talk about things called
we're going to talk about probability
distributions and to do that we need a
we actually need now a third-party
package
so
that is a package that's not part of
your julia installation
and
which leads us to the whole issue of
something called package management
which we're not going to try and cover
in this
workshop
fortunately when you're working in a in
a pluto notebook the package management
is sort of embedded in the notebook if
you like so you don't have to worry
about it too much so let's
load this third party library called
distributions
by going using distributions and then
going let's go control return to get it
to evaluate that
distribution's not current that's
because i didn't know how to spell this
true bit of a panic there
uh
now reevaluating it
and that worked thank goodness
okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to do some random sampling
from some distributions
we're going to use even though we have a
built-in function to do it we're going
to use the
uh the normal distribution and uh we're
going to generate some samples so first
let's let's fix a number of samples that
we're interested in say ten thousand and
now let's not evaluate the cell yet
let's let's put in a bunch of lines and
see what happens
so if uh n equals i say a thousand now
let's define some samples so i'm going
to say samples and i'm going to do some
uh
i'm going to randomly sample
from this distribution from the rep from
the normal distribution
so the normal distribution the way you
get any distribution using this package
is you type the name of the distribution
and then you enter some brackets now if
i put no arguments in here nothing in
between the brackets that says useless
default values which is the standard uh
unit
mean and zero variance
and so that's what i'll do by typing
normal with brackets like that
now to randomly sample from it i just
put rand in front and maybe we want
n of those so that will generate our
samples
and i'll make one more line which is to
now we're going to introduce uh some
non-linearity to our samples
by squaring them
and we're going to use that using that
bit of syntactic sugar from matlab
where we go
dot to the power of 2 which means
broadcast the squaring operation over
all the samples and now i'll allow you
to actually evaluate the cell so let's
go control return
and you'll see a complaint here
and this complaint is
so another idiosyncrasy about
pluto notebooks is that you don't allow
you to put
multiple lines in one cell unlike
jupiter notebooks you have to wrap them
in a begin end block if you want to do
that or split them into separate cells
we'll choose the second option which is
to wrap in a begin end block
the other idiosyncrasy is that the
output of
operations in a notebook always appear
above the input which takes some getting
used to but that's the way it is
so we've got ourselves here some samples
we can click on this thing here because
we're in a notebook we have nice sort of
display options
we can have a little uh inspect that in
more detail if we want
by clicking on the arrow here now what
we're going to do is
fit this
sample to a new distribution so we've
we've squared all the values so now this
is no longer representing
normally distributed data anymore but
let's try and fit it to some other kind
of distribution
so the way we would do that is to use
the fit command this is the command
defined by the distribution package
and let's fit to a gamma distribution
and now i'm not going to put any
parameters in here there's no brackets
because i'm trying to learn what
parameters i i need to use
i just type in samples next
and if i execute this this is going to
fit a gamma distribution to my data so
i'll go control return
and now we have we can see here in the
output
we get an a specific concrete gamma
distribution with various parameters
now i want to kind of see
how good a job this gamma distribution
is at representing that random
sample of data
and to do that we're going to do some
plotting in a second but i can first of
all just do some more
basic things of course i can you know
compute the mean of this particular
distribution
i can uh evaluate the probability
density function for this distribution
say at some point say one
just return
and we see okay that's the value at that
point it doesn't mean too much to me
right now so maybe what i really want to
do is draw a graph so let's go ahead and
do that
and for that i'm going to need uh some
another package
but before i do that i want to show you
one i'll give you a little tip
um
which is
we have this third i said this package
distributions is not part of the the
basic installation it got it's a
third-party package how do you find out
how do you get documentation on
third-party packages well of course we
can still use
the help function and you see in pluto
when you do that
something appears to the righty
automatically so i could do help on pdf
and it tells me about the pdf function
but what if i want to go to the
complete documentation for that package
well there's a nice package another
package which is called
um package online help which i recently
discovered
let's load that package control return
and then let's use a tool from that
package
to
go find the documentation for
distributions so what you go now is you
type in
the at symbol you type docs for
documentation and then you type in the
name of the package that you want help
with
shift return
and that will magically open
the
repository for that package
and you can then on your browser and you
can click on
you know find the documentation
detailed documentation about that
package so now let me just close that
window
we finished
that little side comment there
just looking through the questions here
i'm not seeing
a lot of questions right now maybe
things are going too slowly for people
it's only how so fast you can go um
i won't assume that i'll move on and
show a little bit of plotting and then
we'll talk about data frames
so let's start a new open a new cell
control return will do that
and
let's import some plotting software
i'm going to import some software it's
called a library it's called cairo makey
cairo the city matey m-a-k-i-e
and i'm going to put execute a command
from cairo maki which sets up the kind
of
images that it's going to produce so
that they will
i will see them
nicely in in the notebook
so this is an extra sort of annoying
step you just have to do
so let's now execute that block
ah okay i forgot to put the begin in
block so let's just wrap that and begin
and end
and now that that's loaded and set up
so my next block control return
control return again
i'm going to
put a bunch of code so let me now put in
the beginning because i'm going to
remember now
and this is going to be we're going to
generate some plots we're going to do
two plots
we want to plot a histogram of the data
that we sampled
and we want to plot the pdf of our
function that we fit and see how they
compare
so first let's define the function let's
call that function f the pdf function
so a pdf for what well that distribution
that we fit so that's how we do that
simple as that so now we have a simple
one value one variable function to plot
let's generate some plotting data some x
values we'll call that x s
and let's plot the numbers from
zero to
say the number four
but in steps of and then
of 0.1 which i do by putting 0.1 in
between two colons
so what two columns the start value the
step value and the final value
okay
then
we want a bunch of corresponding y
values and again we're going to use this
matlab syntectic syntactic sugar
this says let's broadcast the operation
f over all values of
x s
so that will generate our y values
and now we're going to uh
make a plot and the plotting command is
called lines
that's going to join all those points
those sequences the points with those x
and y values up together with little
lines to make something that looks like
a curve
x s y s it's
basically what you would probably guess
you need to do
and now i want to
overlay on that plot the histogram
and for that we're going to use the
histogram command but because it's an
overlay i'm mutate i think if this is a
mutating operation and so the command i
want to use is the exclamation mark
otherwise i just get i just generating a
new plot
so let's draw let's get a histogram of
the samples
and
to make sure we're on the same scale i
need to normalize this so i'm going to
choose the normalization option
the pdf
and here we're using
as an example when we need to use a
symbol instead of a string
a number of bins let's say 40 and
we introduce some transparency so we can
see the two different figures
clearly
what that alpha is
and now hopefully
that will all work then there's one last
command which generates the actual
plot on that forces the actual figure to
display which is a current figure means
make the current figure display
so close my end block and
shift return and hopefully oh it works
and we see actually that gamma
distribution doesn't do so too bad a job
so that's plotting
okay any questions
any new questions
i'm not seeing any now
so i am going to move on to the next
thing which is a brief introduction to
data frames
for this i'm going to ask you to open a
new blank notebook so we don't get our
variables confused
so you do that by clicking in the left
hand corner pluto notebook the pluto
icon
i'll go down to new notebook
and
i need to change my
look up my new script
okay so what i think we're going to do
now is i'm going to take a five minute
break
um which you can either use to
experiment a little bit and maybe come
back with some more questions and i'll
use just to to have a little break and
we'll come back in about five
minutes
i think there's a little
okay so that would mean that we're going
to resume at
7 let's say 720 so let me make a little
banner for that let's see if i do that
create a better now
oh well it's 7 20 my time
so i don't know what that is in your
time yeah time is not universal
okay so i'll see you in about five
minutes time from now
there was a banner that says like
back in five or something which is not
very useful banner really so we think
we'll just leave it that and see you in
about five minutes
okay welcome back i hope you can all
hear me
i
had a little chance to
catch up on some of the questions which
were not
appearing until i renewed my link
one question which seems
worth answering was a question about
random numbers
i'm now going to get rid of my picture
because it seems to get in the way too
much of the time
so let's take that away
so a question was about seeding
random number generators so if you want
your random number generating to be
uh reproducible then of course you need
some
control over that so
um you can do this in various ways
there's there's a uh there's a julia
there's a built-in
there's a global
random number generator which is being
used by default and you can see that
global random number generator
by doing the following i think you would
do something like
one two three and this would
uh okay it's gonna plane because of that
and this this then would would um
see the the
local the gen the
global random number generator but you
can also define your own random number
generators so that's sort of the
um and for example you can define them
in the scene
twister
something like this and give that one a
seed so hopefully that works
um and then
now when any random call that you make
if you simply you simply put in the
random number generator you want to use
to generate the
uh your random numbers and that will
work
that's that question okay now i'm going
to turn to
uh to um
data frames for a bit
uh
[Music]
and now i've opened the wrong thing on
my script let's go here
i'm only just going to really just
do a little bit because of time data
frames are a huge subject and you can
find workshops i'm pretty sure in this
conference
about using data frames so the first
thing we're going to do is so but what a
data frame is basically some kind of a
table
which which is in memory so uh it's not
so it's not like a file that that's so
big that you can't fit into memory data
frames are about
tabular data that you want to manipulate
in memory
and here's a very example here's an
example of a table that you can
construct
without actually not a data frame it's a
table you can construct
using ordinary julia that we've already
learned
and the example i'm going to give here
is is the way we're going to do it is
using a named tuple so if i have a named
couple and the values are all vectors
then and they'll all those vectors have
the same length then we have an example
a simple example of a table
so uh maybe these are properties of a
person or something a bunch of people
their ages their heights and we put in a
few numbers here
[Music]
these are rubbish numbers but
um
just want to put something in and maybe
whether they're married or not
through so so true and false you use
lowercase letters
to uh define the booleans in julia so
here is uh a named couple let's see if
that works
right
um so here i mean this is essentially
all the table is is a bunch of vectors
with the same lengths possibly different
types but which have names that's that's
what a table is but doesn't look like a
table the way we've
presented it but if you imagine that
these these
vectors here are actually
represented vertically
and that you align them all up
concatenate them all together then it
would look like a table right
so uh
so that's that's a simple table and it's
a very efficient actually for many
purposes form of representing tabular
data
but it's not very convenient for some
purpose for so for example if i wanted
to just grab a single row of this table
that is the height age and status of a
single individual then it's not very
convenient using the syntax we've
learned to do that it takes a few steps
um it's also
quite complicated then to say filter the
records or c
rows of this table according to some
criterion and and that's where uh
something like a data frame comes in to
its own so let's now load the data
frames package
um i can never remember it i think it's
capital capital
with using data frames
and
now let's create a data frame and what
the first frame data frame that we're
going to create
um let's call it data frame lowercase
we're gonna we're gonna create it by
just uh converting the the
column table that we
defined up above so this is called this
is called a column table
and let's
do this column table
we just put that in in brackets using
this data frame constructor
and then magically um
that's how we that's how we can actually
construct one of these data frame
objects and the first thing we notice is
that it's it has a much nicer display so
now it actually looks like a table
the second thing that we can do let's
control return to get a new cell
is that we can
do what i i described before and we can
filter
this data frame
rows based on some criteria so we go
filter data frame and then we say do row
and then in this block here we say we
specify the criterion so
in this block something has to return
either true and false and in this case
we'll do row dot
uh married
and
say equals true i don't have to write
that um i guess hispanic
and
if i do or let's make it equals false
end and
if i do that i i get a
filtered version of the original
data frame based on that criteria
whether someone is married or not and
then of course you could there's a whole
lot of other things that you can then do
you can
do all the kinds of lots of the kinds of
things that like joins and
group by and different kinds of
operations that you might know from
working on databases in some other
context
for our machine learning that we're
doing today we don't have to know much
about data frames but i think you should
at least be initiated to them and
as i'm going to explain now you should
understand some basic uh
ways that we access the elements
um and to do that i'm going to now
i'm going to first however show you how
you can get a data frame into your
computer
from the outside world some
a data set that
from somewhere else and the somewhere
else that we're going to actually do in
this case is uh
i'm i'm going to introduce it to
something called openml so this i'll
just put in the banner
uh i think i have a banner for this
somewhere
no it's disappeared
so this is just openml.org
and if we go to this uh
website openml.org
i kind of create a better let's just
maybe we can create a new one
copy this in there
copy
and
add view the banner
so if you go to this website then
what you get this openml what is what is
openml it's a machine learning uh it's a
platform for sharing machine learning
uh things so those things could be
things like data you can also share
machine learning runs and
results and so on but we're going to
just be worried about using it as a
source of data
so you click on the on the left here you
see on the left column on data sets
and if we click here we see
[Music]
i don't know where it is
and there's something wrong with the
site today it's not coming up on my
computer
let's come back to that in a moment
maybe it'll come good in a second uh
let's go back to our
notebook which is here
not sure what's going on there uh maybe
that will affect what i try and do here
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
i'm going to introduce a new package
which is called openml
we'll hope that that that should load
that shouldn't be a problem and now
let's grab a data set from openml now um
each data set in openml as i was hoping
to show you here
isn't quite working for some reason has
an associated id which
which i'll show you how to find out in a
minute and we can load data sets in by
using the id so i'm going to call this
data set um
what i call it in my in my um script
i just call it table so i'm going to say
table
i'm going to go open ml
and
say load and then we want the
data set which has the id
42638 so that's 42
63 8.
and once we now what let's let's just do
that and see if it works i mean it may
not work if the site is down
let's see if it works um ah at least
that worked that's good
let's go back to openml it seems to have
half work maybe this is something to do
with my internet connection but anyway
on on your own you can go at some point
visit the site look at data sets and
there's like 4 000 or more data sets
it's just fantastic having data sets
there are you can search the data sets
using various criterion
and then from the id you can then load
them like we're loading here
now after doing this what i've got here
is actually not a data frame and it's
not a column table it's yet another kind
of tabular format called a dictionary
column table and julia has lots and lots
of different tabular formats
and
there's some nice software which has
been written which kind of provides a
common interface so that you can easily
switch between one or other
representation
and we're once again going to use this
fact by
making this into a data frame so we do
the same thing we did before and we
convert this particular kind of table
into a data frame by just saying data
applying data frame to it the data frame
constructor to it and that should give
us
a um
oh okay i should have i
did that in two cells today okay so
that's two cells so now i've i finally
got a data frame of the titanic
data set yay which we're going to be
using in a minute with
samuel
before i turn over to samuel i'll just
mention a few ways things about
more things about data frames let's go
control return
first thing i'm going to do is introduce
you to this command called describe
which gives you a kind of summary
of the fields of our
data set
of our data frame
so on the left here you see the
different variables which are the
different names of the columns for
example age and across here we see
different statistics uh in particular i
want to make you may want to note here
that we have
some missing values which we'll have to
take care of when we do our machine
learning because our decision tree
algorithm
may not like the missing values very
well some
some algorithms do actually but for the
sake of illustration we're going to get
rid of those
um
right so that's the describe command
i'm just looking at the time here i want
to make sure i give samuel plenty of
time
and also time for questions
see if i've got any new questions here
you have to just keep renewing this
okay
um
let me show you how to do some basic
access here
so the first thing that you want to do
is just
access a single element of of of the
data frame so the way we can do that is
with square brackets like it was a
matrix
except but we're free in the in the in
the um
in the second
column variable to use the name instead
of a number so i could say for example
do age and i can either use string or
symbol here i don't think it matters
that's how we get a single row
a single element if i want a single row
then um i can use a one way to do that
is to use a wild card like we did for
just like we did for a raise so i could
go
uh
colon instead of giving a specific row
and that will give me uh sorry i want to
do a column in the other place only
five let's get the fifth row and put a
colon here and that'll give us the whole
um
row maybe i'll just give that a name to
make it um
okay that's what that is it's a row
um we can also get columns the way we
get a column is
um
oh okay well let me just say
how we can access an individual element
within a row let's do that first so an
element within a row we just use this
dot syntax that we saw before so for
example i could get the age for that row
how do we get a single column
well we can access
on how we get multiple rows well it's
more or less the same as we've seen for
for arrays and vectors
or did we do that maybe we didn't do
that let me just show you in case we
didn't so if i want to get multiple rows
i could do something like one rows one
through four for example
that's how i would do that i can still
see this let me get rid of my picture
here i'll get rid of the banner now
so make sure you can see the bottom of
the screen here
um
right so that's how we would get um
multiple rows
the next thing is the question of course
is how do we get a column i'll show you
one way that you can get a column uh the
single column one way you can get a
single column is just to use
the dot syntax that we saw before now
this is a vector so i can
access it like a vector as well and get
a single element in a new way
i think that's all i'm going to say for
now um about
data frames as i said it's a huge
subject a huge thing to learn about and
there are other workshops and more
details in the tutorial that we provide
in the resources
and
samuel may introduce you to some
further commands that as needed in the
machine learning part
and with that i'll just check for any
last minute questions
a lot of questions that aren't ranked
very highly which i tend not to see
uh
latest let's see how to okay
how do i can you close the banner i
can't see what you're typing okay
so the data set that we've loaded was
this titanic data set
you can also get information about it
using more openml commands but i think
i'm not going to go into that detail
here
let's have another last look at openml
ah it's come good
so in open now we if we click on
datasets we see them here and if you
click on a particular data set
it's very slow for me i'm not sure why
then in the in the top left hand corner
there you'll see the id of the data set
okay i think with that i'm going to
um
just go over the questions a bit more
unfortunately i cannot move the banner
someone's asked me to do that i don't
know how to do that
yes
data frames is very popular in machine
learning uh
there are some other options but i think
for most for saying
unless you have a specific thing like
for example time series data or
something like that
if it's if you're looking at mixed data
types then your best uh the most popular
and
most mature platf
package would be data frames
someone's asked how how fit calculates
the approximation
i don't know i suspect it's some kind of
maximum likelihood
thing but i don't actually know
someone asked does cairo make you use
grammar to make the plots so cairo makey
is a is a relatively new plotting
package in julia
um
and but it has there's been a lot of
development effort going into it and i
think it's um there's another package
called plots and they're really the two
main most popular ones plots dot jl and
and makey the maki uh
the mikey has an extension which is
called algebra of graphics which
provides a kind of like alg like grammar
of graphics it's similar to that which
is an add-on so you can if you like
grammar of graphics you like algebra of
graphics and chiramaki has that add-on
and i think that now with that i'm going
to hand over
the session the remainder of my time
to samuel who's going to
lead you into some
actual machine learning
are you ready samuel
off
we see you we see you find samuel but we
just see you we don't see anything else
yet
are you seeing my screen now
uh anthony can you see my screen
uh
yes i can i can see your screen
okay so i'll go ahead and
okay
hello so um
we're going to be going on in this last
section of tutorials we're going to be
looking at um
how we could build a basic machine
learning model
for the titanic data sets and i'm not
going to be going through the titanic
data set um what it is because um
anthony has already gone through that
but i'm just going to show you how
the practice or now you could use um mlg
to build a model for that
so you see already i've already loaded
up
the packages we're going to be needing
um the mlg and the data frames package
so it's something very light and easy so
before we begin first thing you need to
understand about the
emoji
package is the scientific types because
that's what is at the core of the
package
once you're able to
wrap your head around scientific types
on what they are
then i think the rest of the package
becomes easy to use so scientific type
is that basic stuff you need to know
about
mlg
so what scientific types um in mlg what
do we mean by scientific types
it's actually the way we um encode um
data or the way emoji models uh
interpret data you passed into it for
training or evaluation
so
for instance now
in our machine learning polling so in
statistical balance we know we have
different types of data we have discrete
data we have continuous data
we have categorical and so on
so
mlg just wants you to think about um
data in in that light in the statistical
light are we dealing with discrete data
are we doing dealing with continuous
data
if it's discrete is it um integers um
counts data or
is it um something that's categorical or
something like that so that's actually
what you should be focusing on emoji
takes care of the rest by
allowing you to switch between one data
representation to another
so for instance um
we know that
three
um in statistical balance we tend to
take players like account data so
mod has
a way of checking the site type of
object so you could check site type of
three and get count you could check site
type of 3.142
okay and you get continuous so that's
like um
expected
apart from this you you could also check
the site type of complicated objects
like um
arrays of
these scalar objects so in general the
site type of arrays of scalar objects
should give you an abstract array of the
side type of each of those objects
so for example you could check site type
of
let's say i have an array of 2.5
and 8.6
so see because i have an array of um cy
type objects uh
objects of floating type of continuous
type objects basically in statistical
balance
we expect as expected we had abstract
vector continuous
also there's what is known as
categorical array
that's the way we encode um
category category data in julia
and mlg has our own way of representing
that kind of data
so
let me take you to the to the general
structure of scientific types in
mlg
so you see here we have missing textural
ordered factors
multi-class containers and so on and so
forth
uh so for missing the side type of
missing object any missing object
an instance of
so we get missing
so this is actually very important
because this is what we'll be checking
in uh our data because some most data
sets are actually messy and missing so
we're looking for oh do we see missing
an entire site type
information and so on and so forth
so let me let's check what the site type
of the categorical arrays so let me
create a categorical array
you don't necessarily need to know how
to create these because it automatically
converts it for you
so let's and just create a comic
category gallery and
uh let's calculate the site type of this
object
okay
so we see here that the site type of
this categorical array is
abstract vector multiclass multi-class
is one of the ways we we
encode categorical
data in
mlg
another option is if this array was
ordered
if this categorical array was ordered
so i said already it's true um we had
another fact so
um
others worked on multi-class are two
ways of representing um
categorical data
okay so let's um
look at how we're going to
load the data set in question because
we're trying to load uh we're trying to
build a model for the titanic datasets
so
uh antony has gone through a lot of
um
about
openml
so
we're going to use the same
um
open number data set number so to load
up the titanic data set but this time
around because open level drawings
actually generate um a data frame you
can name it something
called a dix column table which is like
a
table source but not necessarily a data
frame so we want to work with data
frames here
so i'm going to convert that into a data
frame so that's here
let me create a data from code dx nodes
data frames
data frame
table
okay so last okay
so this loads up the
data frame so you can see that i have
the titanic data set
yeah i could be just the first element
the first
five rules of the data frame
standard stuff
[Laughter]
and stuff
okay so i can view the first five rows
of the data frame i go to if i want i
wanted i could have checked also the
last
five rows of data frames so see i have a
view of what the data set looks like
[Music]
so we can also check the size of the
data sets
let's check how large
and how wide
data set is
so
you see here it's dataset has about
891 rows and eight coulombs
okay
okay
uh let me pause for a moment and let's
see whether we have any questions of
what i've
discovered so far
[Laughter]
um
samuel you're having a we're having a
bit of static coming in do you want to
try your different microphone and see if
that's any better
oh is this better now
oh it's just the same it's it we can
still understand you it's just a little
bit
uh
annoying i guess
at least i'm hearing a bit of static
do you have a different option for a
microphone no
okay well we'll just we'll just carry on
with it it's just fine i just thought we
would have a try okay carry on
okay
all right okay um
[Music]
one of the questions is um why
site type of one two three is abstract
does this have performance heat i don't
think i get this question abstract what
do you mean by abstract
okay
let's look at another question site
doesn't work for me i get scitec not
defined i have data frames
uploaded emoji and data frames are you
loading the compiled version
uh
let's see
strange
again
so
maybe you could open a new pluto section
then in the pluto session
create a new notebook
and
run using
begin end
and using mlg
using data frames
this should work for you
then if you have this if i make sure
you're using using another import so by
using this you should be able to get
site type
so i don't know whether that has
resolved the problem
[Music]
i'm confused the syntax as in uh openml
load seems like load
was a method of the cloud object of
classifiers in python
but yeah it's i can open
just telling you that um
the
method actually is defined in the openmm
module
that's just what that means
okay let's
go ahead
okay
is this better now
as for
no that's that's not making that doesn't
make any difference
i i think you just carry on the best you
can
okay let's move ahead
i'll pick me
we can hear you we can hear you
hey emmy
uh yes i can hear you can you hear me
okay
we can hear you
okay so let's move on here
all right so um
we could also describe
um the data set we just loaded so you
could use data frames
don't describe
so
doing that
you see you get
in summary statistics of each column any
data sets
and it gives you statistics that are
relevant to the based on the column
types so
some column types do have um some
statistics
for like um p class um coulomb uh it
doesn't have any mean because it doesn't
make sense
categorical objects so it gives you
the the minimum and the maximum
stops like that
so uh all looks good
so now
after after loading data sets and your
data frame you connect to data frame and
you've
checked some stops and at the end we
make sure that um everything is all good
and emoji
is treating our data or is interpreting
our data set
the right way so what we could do there
is
uh using what is called the schema
function so mlj provides us with the
schema function to check to inspect our
data set and make sure that all is okay
so we're going to be using the schema
function a lot in this tutorial and it's
a recommended function to use in your
mlj workflow
so you have emojis
so you call schema
so it will call schema
on our data data frame df notes
okay
um
okay so you can call data frame on your
schema jf nodes
and that gives you
a printed pretty table
so you could see each
columns in the data set each column
names and data sets and
the corresponding site type of the
elements in that column so for example
now you see that here that the p class
column has a site type of
multi-class and the three-year means
that there are actually three unique um
categories right three unique levels in
that p-class data set and
something like um cabin data set you see
is a union of missing multi-class 186 so
i mean this means that um we have about
186 classes
in that data set and we have um missing
among those um
data entries these are their missions
seems like this also you see that you
see it missing here
giving you some flags now okay you tend
to have some missing data in your
submission values in your data set
all right
so i didn't carry on do this because i
said mlj treats expect you to think at
the level of um
scientific types whether you're dealing
with integer data
continuous data categorical data stuff
like that
so
i don't really treat this without having
to go down and look at the weight types
rather than the side types so what we do
is we have um emoji provides you with
the cost function so the quest function
is what we use to
make
the column types
what we want it to basically that's why
so you just pass it
past what you want the prototypes to be
and
it does it
so they have not so in this case you
pass the data the object in this case a
data frame
and
in this case i want to change um i want
to working with the number of spouses
the number of
siblings
that is the ship spouse
okay so
um
okay so the number of siblings slash
spouses so that's what i want to be
working on
[Music]
okay so sip spouse um
all right
so
the number of siblings of spouses is
actually something that should be a
discrete value we cannot have number of
siblings or number of spouses of people
as 3.2 for example it doesn't make sense
to say okay um how many siblings do you
have i have 3.2 siblings or
something like that so
that variable should actually be treated
as discrete variable whereas it's taken
as continuous so what you do is that you
give the name of the variable you want
to change
c
spouse
and you pass in
what you want to change the type you
want to change it to so once you need to
count count is the way we represent
discrete variables
so integers i want to apply count means
like integer types one two three and so
forth so on and so forth
so that's that so
uh i'm gonna oh
and
okay
oops double
all right so
you see this gives me a new data frame
from the so it creates this time you
create you pass it you're doing quas
you're creating a new data frame or a
new object from the previous object
so then you could now
let's check the schema of what we've
done to make sure that okay we're on the
right part so you see that the
uh
the column shift spouse the number of
siblings like number of spouses has
actually been changed
to
something that is discrete
like an integer
uh that's what we call counts okay
now another thing here another
problematic variable here is cabin so
you see that for cabin we have like
186 classes
that's um that'll be too much for an ml
algorithm to undo so it's better to
reduce that number of classes into
something fewer to make more sense
and you see that also there are missing
values in that class data you have
so what one option what we could do is
to actually split
um to actually create a new
um
column that just has two classes
one with missing uh one without missing
so let's create
a function that we use to convert that
so let's create a class function so the
idea is i want to convert classes
into um i want to convert the
cabin class from 196
class instances to just two instances
to
um
without cabin depending on whether the
the
entry had a cabin
or does not have any carbon recorded so
we have class and
so if
is missing
n
but it's just something simple
return without cabin
okay
uh
else
return
ass cabin
when you
you have end
uh julia we have n after the if blocks
or like python different from python
that you don't really need that
you
end your function
so now i have the class function that
help me
convert the entries in the in the carbon
column
if the entry has missing
um
it it gives it converts that entry to a
string called without carbine else it
converts it to something that has cabin
so this is actually converting from
multiple classes to just two classes
so let's apply this
so-called transform so our data set
so we have
begin
okay
df
let's create a new data frame bf2
transform of the original one dataframes
dot transform
so data frames of transform is just
basically a way of
taking your previous data frame
transforming some of the columns so you
pass a transform then copy out
the remaining columns you have
previously
into the new data frames so
my data frame is df1
i'm going to copy out i'm going to
transform the column cabin
and row means that for each row in
in the
cabin
so that's by rule when you show any
admin function
uh incoming um
column pass
apply the function class to it
so
then the output column will also be
named cabin
i know this is quite a lot to get your
head wrapped around
uh
but once you get used to it it's
quite intuitive
okay
so then uh
practice okay
so you can run this let's see we can
make it so yep this works we have um i
say the carbon column has converted so
something
strings without carbon or
ass cabin right
so like i said schema is always your
friend always check schema make sure
that everything you
yeah make sure that mojo is actually
interpreting the data the way you want
it to
so
called schema on the beta frame two
let's see what's going on
yeah so
um you notice that
cabin is now textural right rather than
um multi-class or other factor which is
like categorical so we wanted we won't
actually want the categorical or
multi-class data multi-multi-class site
type uh rather than textual
um what we do is that like i said
mlj provides you with the quest function
so you could just squeeze
um the previous data data frame
so i'm going to quest that
rc
okay
so becoming column
i want it to be multi-class
ot class
okay so see ya now
uh let's check the site type to make
sure it's actually did what
you wanted to do
so checking schema you see
yep
we have what we want we have
uh we have converted it from something
that was previously
186 classes with missing class
uh to something that's just um two class
with no missing so you see that's okay
[Music]
so before we continue because there's
still some
missing
elements here
to treat to take care of let me pause
and see whether we have any questions
okay yeah the question here is changing
the site type
of
from discrete to continuous
importance for machine learning or
conceptuality so it's more of a
conceptual stuff
and
that's actually what it could work
without that but moj
model is actually built on the idea that
based on the idea of site types so it
allows us to suggest to you models that
will probably work well on your data
sets so you could actually search for
models that will do well on your data
set or work on your data set so that's
one of the reasons why thinking that
in terms of scientific types is actually
better than
machine types
another question is julia asked about
the planning packages why should i
choose emoji
and not one of the others
so
mrj is actually more
than
aims to be like more general purpose not
just for
um
[Music]
uh deep learning uh
works on classic machine learning models
and
as well as deep learning also because we
have we have an interface to flux uh
stuff like that
so
it's
aims to provide more like a general um
purpose like interface
to all those different frameworks so
rather than having to learn
one interface from one
package
or then learn how to use your another
interface from another package and stuff
like that all you have everything all in
one place so you just have to learn one
interface
and it have it works well with
other packages including flux because i
think we have um
an interface to flux mlg flux
right then prior to mld we had what we
had in the ecosystem was we had
scattered packages so we decided that
jail was this individual package
different other packages some
so if user wanted to apply any of those
models you have to
use
you have to learn the package syntax for
each of those new level syntax for each
of those packages
and if you want to switch to another
um
under model you have to let the package
syntax for that new model so emoji kind
of provides like it's and a general
interface to all those modules
yeah describe uh is describe the new
show print
uh describe is more like
giving you some research statistics on
data show and prints are more like um
just um giving you representations of
like the data frame like giving you
for prints maybe like texture
representation of the data frame and
stuff like that describe is more like
statistics on
some statistics on each of the columns
of the data frames
all right
let's move ahead
yeah there's a good question what are
the
what are the advantages of mlg compared
to
python cycling uh composability that's
one of the key goals of emoji
we could you could compose models in
ways that
you probably have never thought of doing
so python has some limitations in that
regard or at least if you can do that
it's actually very very difficult to
compose models in
in python so we compare composing
modules in emoji the number of lines of
code you type is small compared to
if you could do the same thing in python
and there are some cases where it's very
difficult to do it in pi and by terms
and scaling
okay let's move ahead
all right so before i treat the how to
handle um embarked
column
let's just um
just personal preference let's split the
data let's show you could
split your data set into
a training and
a test data set
so
let's
do that so emoji has what they call
partition so it allows you to split
so think basically you can think of it
as a way of splitting your data set into
training and test stuff but it's it's
more complicated than that you can do
some other quite
fun stuff
so we have
so i'm going to
create two new variables bf means the
um
training data set they have test the
test data set so i call the partition
function on that
and passing the updated data frame this
is the f3
and
i give it the training um fraction so i
want 70 training that i said that's what
0.7 means so split so that you have 70
percent of training
some some people united assets use for
training
so
then the council pass a random number
you know
[Music]
a number using random imaging um
to sample
but to see that you're not running about
generator
all right so we run this
obviously we have two
data frames first data frame the
training data frame
second data frame the test which is the
test data frame
okay so then
we could check
the
number of rows so let's call data frames
so you see here we have 624 rules
uh let's make sure that it did what we
want so
it's frames.nbc 70
of the data that's
is provided
right
okay
so now let's look at how we could undo
another way of handling the missing data
previously we just converted it because
we had a lot of um classes
and there was just some missing values
in that class
so
yeah so we have a lot of classes then
there was missing values in that class
so now we want to look for look at
another way of handling them missing
data
rather than just finance and giving you
two variables
two classes
so emerging provides what we have what
is known as transformers or
what people regard as unsupervised
modules
so we're going to use a transformer sure
we can use a transformer to
actually fill out
the missing values in the embarked data
sets so you want to fill out fit that
out
so if you look at the embarked data set
the description of the the original
describe function here
in fact you see that
it just has two missings right not quite
much compared to the number of them
[Music]
number of um rules in the data set too
so
it's good if i just use some kind of
imputation method okay
so let's you do a unsupervised model
transformer to do that so i'm going to
name our transformer cleaner
cleans out the missing datasets
so i'm going to use here what is known
as a fill imputer
okay so this is just one of the several
transformers mlg provides we have
feature selector
we have standardizer for example you
want to standardize your data sets you
could use a standardizer so we have
pretty much
most stuff
transforms you need for data analysis
inbuilt as models
okay
so
that's how you create a model so you see
that this model has some parameters
features continuous field finite field
so continuous field finite field and
count field are just functions that
actually undo
each of those columns so continuously we
handle continuous columns in the data
sets counts free will handle count
columns that's columns that has the
count ci type why find it field and
those columns have like either ordered
factor or multi-class ci type any data
features there is just a way of
restricting
your module to just work on a subset of
the data dataset like in terms of
columns you want to undo so in this case
we really want to
focus on
impact
so i could just limit it to say okay um
just do this cleaning on the embark
don't bother about
um other cool notes right
so
oops
pictures
all right so she has completed that
let's move ahead
so
that's a model
what i want to point out or to stress
out here is that
there's another
model in moj is not
they don't
you can't train on a model like you're
doing circuit length so in circuit lane
you could you build your model you have
methods that are kind of like
um
like on that on those uh models so you
could call feet on those models called
predict on those models so in mojo we
separate that stuff so that's another
very key
a
key difference in the medium circuit
length so we separate the idea of a
model from
the idea of
training the model so
to train a model we use what we could
known as machines
so in mlg we have models and we have
machines models are like
the
data that goes into the machine so
imagine like you have the computer
system and you give data and
the machine is like a robot and just the
training and spits out data stuff like
that so machine is what actually does
the training model is the specification
of
how the machine should go ahead during
the training
in the internals and stuff like that so
you can think of it like that
so
in order to train this model i'll create
a machine
okay so machine
so let's call merch
call my machine match
sheet
so we have machine machine
so to create a machine for unsupervised
model
you pass in the
model the instance of the model which is
cleaner in this case
then
passing
it doesn't frame right because on
supervised modules don't need a target
generally though
so
you pass in the data frame this case df
training data frame
which used to do the stuff
so
um
but this we actually create a machine
for you in my chain right it's not done
any training just creates it was not
instructed to do any training and stuff
like that
we could train this machine by calling
feet with a bank
meaning that this machine is this
don't i think
one thing that might be confusing here
is you might think that machine is
actually mutating
your model so don't be deceived the
machine is not actually mutating your
model
it's what you're actually doing is
storing some of the fit parameters in
the machine so it's the machine is like
an object so it's as you train it it
it's recording
information of the training process and
on stuff like that in itself so that's
what we have debunked here not it's not
mutating anything about the model all
right
we call mash
so it fits that strained good
so we could also check let's see what
what happened to this machine what's the
fit what's the parameter so just like in
circuit lane we can also check the
parameters that the
machine
fitted based on the model in view so
let's check that
so fitted params is the function you
call
the coffee departments are passing the
machine that has been trained
so to tell you the information of defeat
parameters like what parameters are
needed to administer as the hyper
parameters that was fit
during the models
sorry not upper parameters too and the
parameters that was fit during the model
so much
she passed that and hola you have
see a
features that were seen during the feed
the app
the
universe transformer
downfield median and stuff like that
so you see this is actually what's we
was modified the embarked columns so it
filled it with
s
anyway some missing it's filled with s
so this what's important
all right
so now we have trained our transformer
to do the
fitting to do the transforming that
means anyways he's missing it transforms
the data and gets rid of missing
so let's actually get rid of missing
i mean go to training and data sets so
let's to do that we have the transform
so when you
you train a transformer you can call
transform
on a given um object input data frame or
table and it transforms it based on the
specific
details of the transformer so let's
transform
our
machine to image.transform
if right
and
this actually transforms your
your test
data set right
there's no more missings here and
you could check that schema
bfc
there's no missing
but likewise it could also transform
your
training data sets yep oh that's your
training dataset i will transform so you
can transform your test data sets
mlg dot transform
[ __ ]
give test
okay
so that actually transforms
transform your your
test dataset also and you can also check
the schema of that
okay
good
let me pause it again see whether there
are any questions we need to address
yeah
it's always nothing about stratified
partitions and i think antony has
addressed that already
um
we have ways of doing that using
crossbow validation i think we have a
satisfied crossbow validation
you could use for that
yeah you can also just you can also just
use
do a stratified partition directly
oh um yeah yeah
okay
and what else i think the rest has been
answered i think good
let me refresh to see if there's any
question we missed
okay no new questions
i take it that we
understanding uh
stops okay that's good let's move ahead
all right so now we've transformed our
training data sets to dfc and our test
data set to dfc test
so now let's unpack because we want to
build a supervised model now
so let's unpack the supervised model has
targets and
features so want to unpack each of these
uh all one called splits you know split
the targets from the the features so
that's what so for the training data set
we'll split the target from the features
and for the test data set or split the
target from the features
so let's do that
so
we're going to be using what is called
unpack
so it provides your pack function for
this
so it's also another nice function
simple way you can think about it is
just
a way of splitting
the targets from
the features but you could do much more
than that so you check the docs string
for unpacked you could do
more than basic stuffs so for now i just
want to deal with the basis so why x
y is the target so the way the function
works is
the first output output
pool the first output is the target why
the rest is the features
so when you remove the target the
meaning of your system features
when passing the data frame you want it
to unpack
target from and you tell it
which column is the target so in this
case we survived colon that's what we
are trying to build our mother i want to
know
build a model to tell predicts
i need the video i will survive
will survive or not
on
and the other one is our features
okay
so let's check the side type of these
objects
in terms of mlk but sci type is
what we do so
cy type of why
it's actually
a vector of um multi-class so it means
that this the target is actually
categorically it has levels right
and that's just two levels in it that's
good
we could check what are the levels
all right
zero and one so there's two levels
that's good
so you also want to check maybe you want
to check the site type of
x
it's actually a table
uh
for x less it's better to check the
schema
okay so you notice here that the
right
um
have i transformed impact oops i'm using
the wrong df i should have used tfc
thing what i noticed that
so this should be dfc not df
so i said schema is your friend
so using schema you pick up this kind of
silly mistakes
the fc is our transformed dataset that
have been looked as missing so we can
see i'm back there's not been any
missing value okay
all right oh it's good
okay
likewise we can do the same thing for
the test data sets
so let's
transform it so y test
and x test
same way you use them
functionality so i'm park
ef test
okay
equals to
survive
so
like i said earlier on what this will do
is take your data frame which is df test
and tell it which column is the target
that's what is specified telling us the
target is survived so to speak that so
why test and there anyone will be your
features which is x test so we run this
again you have to return to a tuple
first target another one is a table
so you could also check
alian like we did because you check the
site type
of white test
and
schema
okay
of x
tests
only is
good up stack and x test
why are you making a mistake so dfc test
okay
schema is your friend
all right so um
now let's go into model building of
of um
converted
and we split uh
our data sets into training and tests
and also we know the targets from it so
we have training target test targets
um
[Music]
training features test features
so
having this kind of data set
we might be overwhelmed what kind of
models can we apply to this kind of
data sets so
locally for us remedy has a model search
and
matching functionality so we could
actually filter out models that actually
work well on a data set
so
the way you do it is called models
matching
you're passing your x which is your
features so you're going to find models
that match your features and your
targets
and why
it runs so it gives you
so here we have about four models cd
names there
uh
we can actually pass this to pizza frame
should be possible
it's uh
him
yep it's possible so this is better view
all right
most things in mlg is actually table
sources so you can always convert them
to maybe more profit table if you wish
to
so
uh you see that we have four models
constant classifier decision tree
classifier deterministic constant
classifier random forex classifier
so for this model we're going to for
this um tutorial we're going to be using
the
um decision tree classifier
all right
and we can check more information about
this about each of these classifiers so
maybe we want to say what's
maybe after scoring through the stuff
you needed more information about each
of these classifiers you could then
do
doc so you could check the doc streaming
of each of these stuffs so
i'll give you the name of the classifier
decision tree
classifier
and i also give the package because
there might be different packages that
have that but with the shortcut
classifier it's the one from better ml
package that actually fits your data
sets other decision tree classifiers
might not be perfect for your data set
but this tells you that
the decision tree classifier coming from
the better ml packages
will work work for you that ain't
any issues
better email
oh yes here's the basic information so
for now this is really really basic but
there's actually projects uh that we're
currently going to make this actually
more pretty
and more informative so look out for
that
so then um
after we have checked our we've checked
the what the model is all about right oh
yeah seems this is what i want this is
what i need
thank you mlj so then you then have to
load the data so what do you do you
begin and
so let's call it tree
so
you know the instance of the model you
have to know the model i mean so you
know the instance of the module the type
of the model first then instantiates
that
so to do that we have the upload macro
so i thought marco takes in the
the package name
right so the as a package name the model
name so decision
tree
classifier
okay
and
also you need to add
the
package it's coming from so most times
sometimes most times yeah you might
notice at the package name if maybe
that's the only model in the entire mlg
universe so but um for edition three
classifier that's not the only model
yeah several other models
that
has that same name so you also need to
add package name right so you add
package name
um
better email
okay
so after you've when you brought it into
your environment then
you then
create an instance so first note first i
what are the type i brought in the type
so we have that model type you can name
it anything i just named it tree you can
name it anything
then after that i then instantiate it so
we have like an object so
so
i created the model so this is like the
type this is actually the model right
an instance of the module
so we can see that the model has several
hyper parameters that we're not going to
actually go into because we don't have
time for that
all right so um
yeah so now we have our module what next
what should we do
when i said model
um creating a model is not you can't
train using your media model is just
giving you the information
you have to create a machine to do the
training so when you pass a model to the
machine the machine knows okay how to go
about the training stuff right so
machine is like a robot that just
takes inputs from model computer does
the training and keeps your output and
you can do several other stuff
so i need to create a machine if i
actually want to train this model
so i use beginning
so let me call it match t this time
around
uh we get machine so early on
for unsupervised model we we just add
the
model name and we add
the
features right but for supervised model
along
apart from the features you also need to
have the target right so you have why
target here passed it to it
okay
then
let's run this first and
you see that affiliate machine nothing
happens just a machine so you wanted to
machine them to fit
the stuff you then cannot confit
and it gives you your fitted stuff right
so we have a trained machine now right
machine training
okay
so
what do you want to get predictions okay
we train this machine someone just comes
around and says okay look at this group
of people let's see
um would they survive on the titanic or
they die
so it's okay cool you just
you have to predict function similar to
circuit network
so you're passing your machine
so early on in on supervised models we
use transform transform you pass in your
machine and you're passing that the
feature what you want to transform
suppose supervised you're passing your
you pass in your machine called predict
on it and
you pass in the
the test data set
so
all right
um match t
so you see that you have
different
um predictions here
and this is actually what you call
probabilistic predictions so each row of
the prediction is actually probably six
objects so when you see in emoji you see
univariate finite objects it tells you
that this is actually a probabilistic
prediction so it might be strange to
people that maybe called predicting
circuit lane and gets like um
um
actual
um
predictions in terms of whether or not
someone survives this this gives the
probabilities
of each case so for which we'll look at
for example the third item the
probability of
zero is um not survive one is survived
so probably of no surviving is about
zero point two four
and the probability of surviving is
about zero point eight for that third
individual right so this probability
distribution um
so probability predictions so what if
you want to get
um
even you want actually that you want
individual predictions like um singular
predictions whether or not someone
survived so these are now options what
you could do you could just say okay
let's call predict mode
so emery provides the predict mode
functions you pass the my
machine right
and you get x test
when you come around you see you get
actual prediction so life survives not
survived like that okay another way of
doing it is that if you have your
probabilistic predictions you could code
mode with broadcast mode on each of
those stuffs it will take the most
likely so this actually create mode is
giving you the most likely
um case so
to predict that and similar answers you
get same thing it's right so right now
so
okay
so what if we want to after we've done
all these predictions and
[Music]
we're confident that we've built a great
model and stuff like that
how do we know we have repeated a great
model so you might want to actually test
the performance of your model so for
this we have what is known as
performance metrics performance measures
in mrt so emoji has advanced array of
performance measures so in case you're
looking for performance measures maybe
you want to use some in your package you
could just check out mrjps for that so
let's check so check out some
performance measures
so i released about the performance
measures emoji ads you could just call
the measures
bracket
this gave me something 50 so i'm going
to pass it to the data frame i'm going
to pick a data frame for it
[Music]
we see we have a lot of measures well
the spice goes and stuff like that
so for public dis um
probabilistic predictions um
let's
we
get
want to use a log loss
right
so let's call log loss
that's the probability our predictions
as beginners always the first argument
why the actual
is the second argument so y test
it and you see
this gives you the log loss
also you could also check um
let's see
when you want to check accuracy
accuracy doesn't work for basic
distributions you need actual you need
actual
um
scala like in terms of labels you
predict categorical so category
predictions whether or not someone
survived or didn't survive so for that
case
maybe i have been
i wanted to get the mood a bit so this
gives me like i said earlier on this
gives me
um scalar predictions like the wave
everything psychic name so
n pass y test
so it gives you
a crazy measure so that one was log loss
and
this was a question
okay
so i think with that we've come to the
end of the tutorial
so i'd like to check
let's check if there are any questions
can mojo find a pie touch model
for
your giving data set
no we have
flocks we haven't we have links to flux
what's known as emojifloc.js so you
could check out moduleflux.com so
um julia we we use flux to jail so
that's our deep learning library
so yep we have the interface to that
library
okay i think other ones has been
answered
uh perhaps um i'll answer the question
which was also i think implicit in the
previous one
how would you how do you do a neural
network and why does models matching not
find any well the reason here is that
our data set at the moment has our
features have mixed type so we've got
features like
cabin for example which is
categorical and then we have continuous
features like age i suppose
so most models
raw models don't handle data of mixed
types so we don't find many when we
provide data of mixed type where if you
were to provide some kind of
pre-processing to your data for example
one hot encoding which would convert all
your categoricals to continuous then all
your features would be continuous and
when you went models matching x y you
would find a lot more models
including the flux models
which are the neural network models that
we interface
that's that question
last chance for questions
yeah
might give you a lot of time for
questions we wanted to get your
questions here's another question what
is the log loss so log loss is also
known as cross entropy so maybe you know
what is that um
so the if it's a classification problem
like this one
what you would do is um
you would look um
at
uh
you so the model in that case is
predicting our model is predicting
probabilities
so you would go to each um particular
observation and you say well was it um
was the true value survived uh was the
true value um predicted or not i'm sorry
you you take what the um
what you do you take the uh
um
you take the examples where um
i'm going to mess up the definition
trying to do it off the top of my head
why don't we just leave it
as
it's another name for it is the cross
entropy and you can look up
the um definition so i don't
uh eat my word put my foot in my mouth
um
any other questions so there's two more
questions
there's one on our assignment
and how would you plot the roc curve so
there um would you like me to
yeah you answer
go ahead yeah
so there's a there's a function to to
compute
the points on an roc curve it's just
called roc
and if you type question mark roc you
can get it
probably hopefully get
some information about that there are
also tutorials that can demonstrate that
perhaps i'll mention um
share my screen for a moment um
okay
is that right samuel
uh yeah
if you go to um
mlj and
the
i don't know if you search for mlj.jl
hopefully that's the best way that's one
way to find it
and you can find um
well okay it's taking me here so i click
on documentation and this is the basic
manual for the package you can find a
lot more here
and in particular beginners will be
interested in this section called learn
so if you click on learn there's a bunch
of resources if you actually are an
experienced machine learning
practitioner already i highly recommend
this tutorial called mlj for data
scientists so if you already know about
machine learning and you're simply
wanting to transition from another
platform for example that's a really
good tutorial and there's an example of
an roc curve in there
other basic things that you would do
confusion matrix
and then of course hyper parameter
optimization controlling iteration
um
and so on and pipelining models so when
you take several models so for example a
supervised learning model and some
pre-processing steps
and you combine them together into one
super model
so this this particular tutorial lives
at a site called data science tutorials
which have
more tutorials
on how to use mrj including some basic
things but also some
more less less basic things and some
some versions of a popular textbook
called
introduction to statistical learning so
that popular textbook has a bunch of um
laboratories i think they're written in
r and they've been converted here to
julia so that might be something
interesting to you
and also a bunch of end-to-end examples
so there's again there's a link to this
this tutorial site from the learn
that learn thing here
okay let's see there's some more
questions
um are bayesian models so at the moment
uh
we have that we have only kind of a
proof of concept for some
probabilistic programming packages
there's a probabilistic programming
package in julia called sas soss
and
we interface just some simple models for
there
but not really
full integration at the moment
uh let's see what other questions we
have
um
when i go to something
i see this package was updated one year
ago
oh that's because you're not actually
looking at ml so there's a question
about this particular site so you've
looked for mlj and you've been taken to
a site but that's actually a site that
just summarizes other sites it's not
you're not looking at the raw
um
package or it's all the information
about when it was last updated is out of
date
so if we go to um
mlj is being actively developed so if
you come here i mean you can see
uh seven days ago there was something so
yeah
this is actually just a kind of
a package that sucks in other packages
yeah um the main one where all the
activity is is called mlg base actually
what other questions do we have
why not do data preparation including
imputation and then split into test and
training
that's possible you can do that that's
possibly yeah it's your preference
yeah
um
if you it's kind of depends if you are
using an imputation method which
generalizes to new data you may want to
include that as part of your overall
pipeline
yeah
and then if you're using if you're using
a method that doesn't generalize to new
data then you have no choice and you
have to
do it first
what is the practical purpose use of
separating the model and the machine
like this
well
the actual reason that we do this
uh
has to do with model composition so
when we designed mlj we had
the idea that we wanted
uh to be more to more flexibly be able
to combine models so for example
a popular thing way of combining models
in machine learning competitions is
called model stacking
and so then model stacking you blend the
predictions of multiple models together
and so on and if you try and build such
a stack using say another package like
psychic learn you just can't do it you
need a third-party package so when we
designed nlj we wanted model composition
to work very well and it just turned out
that this machine this this extra little
abstraction of machine
was very useful for model composite from
the model composition point of view so
it seems just a little bit weird if
you're not used to it when you're just
doing ordinary fit predict
but when you go ahead when you when you
generalize this and you're doing model
composition combining models
then the same syntax can just be used
that you're already used to in that more
advanced setting so that's the reason
for it
uh
any other questions
two more
oh does mlj interact with fast ai dot jl
in any way
uh no it doesn't
no and are they distinct from one
another well the dip
there is a there's actually a julia
discord this question was asked on julia
discourse
and but i'm not sure everyone has access
to that um but if you look on julia
discourse you might see something i like
comparison between mlj and flux that
kind of discussion but i can see here so
um
fast ai is is a is
is extra boiler you know um sits on top
of of flux which is the kind of a core
package for providing
neural network or deep learning type
models
so um if you're focused on deep learning
models then fast ai provides you
with a lot of extra
sort of boilerplate code that you would
want um that you that sits on top of
that so it makes it convenient to
actually more convenient to quickly uh
build and train uh models
using um your networks
so mlj is a machine learning toolbox but
it's not focused on on your network so
it's more general it's interested in
giving you a possibility of interacting
with a much larger class of models
so
um in that sense their
their focus is different at least that's
my best understanding of the differences
of the packages so if all you ever want
to do is neural networks you might find
that fast ai is is is more helpful to
you but if you're interested in
comparing neural networks with some
other models then maybe you want to use
mlj so that's kind of an answer
is it one machine per transformer for
example can you have one machine that
imputes and the decision tree
so
each machine points to a single
set model or set of hyper parameters but
it's possible to have
different um
so i mean that's a maybe there's a i'm
not quite sure if i'm answering the
question i think
in terms of pipeline you could combine
transformers
you could compose transformers if you
wish to then you pass them into single
machine that's possible
now one one pad design pattern that
comes up here is quite interesting is
target transformations because
uh in a pipeline when you want to
transform the target first you you
transform the target and then you use
that in your training but then after you
predict you want to transform your you
want to inverse transform your target
back to the original scale that you were
interested in so that means you have to
use the learn parameters twice once when
you transform for the sake of training
and once when you inverse transform so
that you return the predictions back to
the scale that that you started with
that means you're using uh the same
machine but you
different operations on it or if you
like the same learned parameters but you
use them twice
and this machine sort of abstraction
actually makes that much easier so you
can have this is you could have a
when you're combining models and with
light that way
you can you can do that you can
reuse the same learn parameters at
different places in your pipeline
essentially
hopefully that gives them sort of an
answer that question
and there's another question
yeah
oh so this is uh
i think it's talking about reinforcement
anymore it wasn't learning no so i think
reinforcement learning is going to
remain out of scope for mlj at least for
the moment
um
yeah
any more questions
see mr no more questions
seems like there's no more questions
well thank you everyone for joining us
um
uh
i hope you got something out of this and
it's it's um
preparing a workshop that works for a
wide audience is quite challenging but
hopefully you've managed to uh get
you've each got managed to get something
out of it thanks for the i've got we got
some positive feedback thank you very
much
okay
um
have a good uh enjoy the rest of the
conference and perhaps we'll see you
around in one of
the um
shared forums
i'm gonna now end the broadcast
yeah cheerio
bye